the European Union's representative in
Palestine says Israeli settlers are in
his words terrorizing at Palestinian
civilians
Von bergsdorf is touring a village that
was recently attacked one of several
targeted since the killing of four
Israelis on Tuesday
according to the accounts we have
received from numerous sources indeed a
group of settlers many many settlers
came here
I would call them terrorist Setters
because they spread Terror in the
vicinity and in the neighborhood here
by shooting with live rounds at fire at
Palestinians warning 12 people killing
Omar Jabara and also setting several
houses and cars on fire luckily not many
more were actually injured and only
nobody was killed apart from Omar where
as I said try to save the lives of those
injured
a more Israeli condemnation has come
from the un's human rights Chief Volker
Turk says Israel's occupation is the
root cause of the violence and is
warning that the situation risks
spiraling out of control well Israeli
government has approved further
expansion of illegal settlements
pledging additional support for
settlements security minister itamar Ben
gavier is urging what he calls a
large-scale military operation we have
two teams covering these developments
Imran Khan is standing by in occupied
East Jerusalem but first let's cross to
live now to Harry Fawcett who's in
Ramada for us and Harry are they likely
consequences then of these kind of
remarks for Palestinians on the ground
well these were very strong remarks
coming from the EU representative but it
was an extremely large-scale attack on
this Village on Wednesday and the
complaint from Palestinians over many
years has been that the International
Community should do more than than speak
in in very uh strong terms that it needs
to take more action I'm sure that some
will be feeling that way again after
this however I suppose the best that
could be hoped for would be some kind of
of influence behind the scene some kind
of pressure put on the Israeli
government certainly there has been
condemnation from some on the Israeli
side as well about this not least from
the Israeli Army of the acts actions of
the settlers on Wednesday but it's only
one of many such attacks it's the most
uh it's it's the largest scale that
we've seen in recent days but there have
been a mushrooming of these sorts of
attacks since the uh the shooting attack
by Palestinians on uh settlers on
Tuesday afternoon in which four settlers
were killed and what a what's also been
clear and has been
um reported by by locals in this
incident and others uh that as far as
they're concerned the Israeli Army does
not come into intervene or protect them
in fact the the person who was killed in
termosiah on Wednesday locals say he was
shot by an Israeli soldier not by one of
the Armed settlers so there is a huge
amount of tension there's been a lot of
violence already this year it's been
accelerating again in recent days and I
don't think many here expect it to tail
off anytime soon Harry Fawcett thank you
for that
well Imran Khan is an occupied East
Jerusalem Forest now in Imran an
Unapologetic response from Israel's far
right dominated coalition
that's absolutely right etymar Ben
gavier was actually touring uh the
Avatar a legal settlement now all
settlements are actually illegal under
is uh international law but this one's
actually illegal under Israeli law and
that's where he said uh that there
needed to be a large-scale operation in
the West Bank more settlements needed to
be built and tens of thousands of what
he calls terrorists needed to be uh
killed now he's been using language like
that for many many years but right now
he is the national security minister
he's in charge of the police so his
statements now carry some weight but
they also controversial within Israel
itself prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
convened a security consultation meeting
with all the relevant parties the Army
the intelligence Services
Etc after the events uh in uh Janine um
and what he just cost there actually was
something that Ben gevir wasn't actually
invited to despite the fact that he is
the national security minister now leaks
from that meeting suggested that the
reason he wasn't invited is uh and
according to one's horse the words were
he's a barking dog without any fight and
he is causing more trouble than frankly
he's worth and that's something that we
don't really hear from Israeli
politicians when they're criticizing
other Israeli politicians but clearly
bengov is a very controversial figure so
although he has been saying things like
this for many years the words do carry
some weight now but the Army isn't
really interested in a large-scale
operation in the West Bank and prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu is a man who
tends to listen to his generals
Imran Khan life resting occupied East
Jerusalem thank you